foreign
what's up y'all as always welcome to the
channel so we're continuing our series
and examining the Jesus of adventism up
and against the Jesus of history and
scripture so far we've talked about how
Jesus was supposedly exalted to be made
equal with the father and that he's not
the Lord God Almighty as well as he
doubted his own Resurrection because
Satan was able to manipulate his mind if
you miss those parts the link to all of
them is in the description box down
below today we're going to look at the
high Priestly role of the Adventist
Jesus in comparison to the true Christ
but first like we've been doing let's
establish the facts on this matter from
the scriptures it's going to be a bit of
a longer video today but this is
important so grab a Bible and follow
along let's start by looking at Hebrews
6 19-20 where it says
we have this as a sure and steadfast
anchor of the Soul a hope that enters
into the inner place behind the curtain
where Jesus has gone as a forerunner on
our behalf having become a high priest
Forever After the order of Melchizedek
so at his Ascension Jesus Christ as a
high priest entered behind the curtain
that only the high priest could enter
which was into the most holy place that
is to say as a man he entered into the
presence of God in heaven he did so not
after the levitical aaronic priesthood
but after the order of Melchizedek he
goes on in the seventh chapter to refer
to Genesis 14 regarding the tide that
Melchizedek received showing that he was
greater than Abraham because Abraham
gave tithes to him We're told that
another reason why Melchizedek is
greater than Abraham in 7 4-8 and it's
because Melchizedek is the one who did
the blessing so why is he mentioning
this his point is to ultimately show the
superiority of the melchizedekian
priesthood over and against the
levitical aaronic one the evidence of
this is in Hebrews 7 9-10 it can be said
that Levi paid tithes to to Melchizedek
through Abraham because as a descendant
of Abraham Levi was present in his
great-grandfather who gave his tithe in
other words by blessing Abraham
Melchizedek also blessed Levi and in
receiving tithes from Abraham
Melchizedek received tithes from Levi
which means Melchizedek and his
priesthood are greater than the
levitical priesthood this Superior
priesthood is the overarching point and
theme of Hebrews 7 through 10 but
something else that's important to
notice is found in Hebrews 8 1-2 where
it says
now the point in what we're saying is
this we have such a high priest one who
is seated at the right hand of the
Throne of the Majesty in heaven a
minister in the holy places in the true
tent that the Lord set up not man
so after walking through some of the
ways that Christ priesthood is superior
to the levitical one he tells us the
point which is that believers do indeed
have a high priest but unlike the
levitical one our high priest entered
behind the veil and sat down at the
right hand of God this is in contrast to
the levitical priest who never sat down
because the work was never finished he
would enter in one time on the day of
atonement leave and come back the
following year repeat the author says as
much in Hebrews 9 6-10 where he writes
these preparations having thus been made
the priests go regularly into the first
section performing their ritual duties
but into the second only the high priest
goes and he but once a year and not
without taking blood which he offers for
himself and for the unintentional sins
of the People by this the Holy Spirit
indicates that the way into the holy
places is not yet opened as long as the
first section is still standing which is
symbolic for the present age according
to this Arrangement gifts and sacrifices
are offered that cannot perfect the
conscience of the worshiper but deal
only with food and drink in various
Washings regulations for the body
imposed until the time of reformation
so we're clearly told that the levitical
priests did their daily work in the Holy
Place known as the outer apartment and
the high priest could enter into the
second apartment the most holy Place
only once a year on the day of atonement
but then he tells us something
fascinating in verse 8 we're told that
the way into the holy places is not yet
open for us while this levitical aaronic
priesthood work is going on it was only
open to the high priest once a year
while the levitical priesthood work was
going forth man had no direct access to
God this is what is meant by the first
apartment being symbolic of the present
age then in the next two verses he says
the following
but when Christ appeared as a high
priest of the good things that have come
then through the greater and more
perfect tent not made with hands that is
not of this creation he entered once for
all into the holy places not by means of
the blood of goats and calves but by
means of his own blood thus securing an
eternal Redemption
so did you get that unlike the levitical
priest who entered in by means of the
blood of an animal and then left to
return the following year our great high
priest Jesus entered one second time by
means of his own blood and he just got
done telling us that when he did this he
sat down and that's where he's remained
but then it gets even more interesting
in verses 24-28 he expounds even further
by saying
for Christ is entered not into holy
places made with hands which are copies
of the true things but into heaven
itself now to appear in the presence of
God on our behalf nor was it to offer
himself repeatedly as the high priest
enters the holy places every year with
blood not his own for then he would have
had to suffer repeatedly since the
foundation of the world but as it is he
has appeared once for all at the end of
the ages to put away sin by the
sacrifice of himself and just as it is
appointed for a man to die once and
after that comes judgment so Christ
having been offered once to Bear the
sins of many will appear a second time
not to deal with sin but to save those
who are eagerly waiting for him so
Christ incarnated bore the sins of many
was crucified died and buried he
resurrected on the third day and this
sacrifice put away sin unlike the
levitical priest whose animal sacrifice
never did away with sin Jesus's
sacrifice of himself did and that's why
we can have a cleansed conscience the
author actually tells us in Hebrews 10
1-4 that the work of the levitical
priest dealing with sin was a constant
reminder to the people that their sin
hadn't been dealt with and this is why
those sacrifices couldn't cleanse the
conscience this is another point of
differentiation and why Christ is better
and shows yet again the differentiation
between Jesus and the levitical priests
continuing in chapter 10 verses 11-13 we
read this
every priest stands daily at his service
offering repeatedly the same sacrifices
which can never take away sins but when
Christ had offered for all time a single
sacrifice for sins he sat down at the
right hand of God waiting from that time
until his enemies should be made of
footstool for his feet
so as mentioned earlier Jesus Christ
entered into the presence of God one
single time by the means of his own
blood and sat down where he is now
ruling and reigning as a priest king
remember the other unique feature of
Melchizedek he was a king of Salem not
just a high priest so another
differentiator is that Jesus is a priest
king unlike Aaron and the Levites Christ
High Priestly work entails a kingly work
as well he is presently ruling and
reigning where he will remain until all
of his enemies are made his footstool
finally in Hebrews 10 19-22 we see the
following point I want to look at it
says
therefore Brothers since we have
confidence to enter the holy places by
the blood of Jesus by the New and Living
Way that he opened for us through the
curtain that is through his flesh and
since we have a great priest over the
house of God let us draw near with a
True Heart in full Assurance of Faith
with our hearts sprinkled clean from an
evil conscience and our bodies washed
with pure water so do you remember what
was said back in 9 8 that while the work
of the first apartment was still going
on the way for us into the holy places
was closed off well here he tells us
that a New and Living Way has been open
for us and it's through the blood of
Jesus since this is the case that has to
mean that the levitical priesthood work
and all of its Duties are not happening
anymore that work is no longer standing
so I know that was a lot of information
and I hope you were able to follow along
what's important to note is that the
levitical priesthood work is finished
sin has been dealt with Jesus is ruling
and reigning presently and he entered
into the presence of God one single time
and sat down as a priest King where he
remains mediating on behalf of his
people while his enemies are being made
a footstool now I want to look at the
Adventist Jesus and his high Priestly
role since the Adventist Church wants to
assure us they believe Jesus is after
the order of Melchizedek we just looked
at what all that entails so keep that in
mind as we examine in early writings on
page 55 Ellen White documents down what
she claims to have seen in vision and
describes an interaction she claims to
have had with Jesus himself it's a bit
long but she writes
I saw the father rise from the throne
and in a flaming Chariot go into the
holy of holies within the veil and sat
down then Jesus rose up from the throne
and the most of those who were bowed
down arose with him I did not see one
ray of light pass from Jesus to the
careless multitude after he arose and
they were left in perfect Darkness those
who arose when Jesus did kept their eyes
fixed on him as he left the throne and
led them out a little way then he raised
his right arm and we heard his lovely
voice saying wait here I'm going to my
father to receive the kingdom keep your
garment spotless and in a little while
I'll return from the wedding and receive
you to myself then a cloudy Chariot with
wheels like flaming fire surrounded by
Angels Came to where Jesus was he
stepped into the Chariot and was born in
the holiest where the father sat there I
beheld jesus a great high priest
standing before the father on the Hem of
His Garment was a bell and a pomegranate
a bell and a pomegranate Those Who Rose
up with Jesus would send up their faith
to him in the holiest and pray my father
give us thy Spirit then Jesus would
Breathe upon them the Holy Ghost in that
breath was light power and much love joy
and peace we've looked at this quote on
the channel before and while there are
many problems they're in notice she says
Jesus is in heaven wearing the levitical
priesthood garments mentioned in Exodus
28 and Leviticus 8. this is why the
Adventist Jesus is depicted the way he
is in their art why would Jesus be
wearing the garments of a priesthood
that he isn't after the order of
furthermore the Bells on the Hem of the
Garment had to do with notifying those
outside that the priest was still active
at work and hadn't died something Christ
has no risk of Exodus 28 43 says that
Aaron and the priests were to wear these
garments so that they will not incur
guilt and die they were unique to the
aaronic priesthood but also notice she
talks of Jesus moving from the holy
Place into the most holy place with the
father this contradicts what the author
of Hebrews told us this move from the
holy place to the most holy supposedly
happened in 1844 when describing what
the Adventist Jesus was doing as a high
priest before and after 1844 Ellen White
says the following in the great
controversy on page 428
in the service of the Earthly Sanctuary
which as we've seen is a figure of the
service in the Heavenly when the high
priest on the day of atonement entered
the most holy place the ministration in
the first apartment ceased God commanded
there shall be no man in the Tabernacle
of the congregation when he goeth into
making atonement in the Holy place until
he comes out so when Christ entered the
holy of holies to perform the closing
work of the atonement he seized his
ministration in the first apartment but
when the ministration in the first
Department ended the ministration in the
second apartment began when in the
typical service the high priest left the
holy on the day of atonement he went in
before God to present the blood of the
sin offering in behalf of all Israel who
truly repented of their sins so Christ
had only completed one part of his work
as our intercessor to enter upon another
portion of the work and he still pleaded
his blood before the father in behalf of
Sinners elaborating further in Christ in
his Sanctuary on page 182 she says this
at the time appointed for the Judgment
the close of the 23 100 days in 1844
began the work of investigation and
blotting out of sins all who have ever
taken upon themselves the name of Christ
must pass its searching scrutiny both
the living and the dead are to be judged
out of those things which were written
in the books according to their works
so prior to 1844 the Adventist Jesus was
doing a work in the Holy place in a
sanctuary in heaven like that of the
levitical priesthood so question for you
how is that possible when the author of
Hebrews told us that the holy Place work
is no longer happening because a way for
us to enter into the presence of God has
already been opened through the blood of
Christ there is no need for a first
apartment Ministry any longer that is
not what Jesus was doing from his
Ascension until 1844. unless the book of
Hebrews was written after 1844 this
isn't possible the author of Hebrews
also told us that Jesus has already put
sin away at The Cross by the sacrifice
of himself and he's seated showing that
the work is finished he is reigning as a
priest king currently making all of his
enemies a footstool and mediating on
behalf of his people he didn't move into
the most holy place after 1844 to begin
investigating who is and isn't truly his
to then blot out the sins of those who
were found worthy no he entered in one
time into Heaven itself sat down where
he's remained until all of his enemies
are made his footstool the work is
finished so yet again we have a high
priest that more closely resembles that
of the levitical priesthood not
Melchizedek so to recap the Adventist
Jesus is wearing levitical priesthood
garments was doing a holy Place Ministry
analogous to that of the levitical
priesthood until 1844 he didn't enter
the most holy place until 1844 is still
working on putting sin away and is
investigating to see who are truly his
and who he is just in Saving compared to
the Jesus of scripture and history who
is ruling and reigning as a priest king
entered the most holy Place once at his
Ascension and sat down on his throne
dealt with sin and put it away at the
cross provides a cleansed conscience
signifying that our sin has already been
dealt with and mediates on behalf of a
people he knows so we could go on and on
and on examining more issues but we will
save those for another video the more
you examine the finer details the more
obvious it becomes that the Jesus of
Ellen White and adventism is sadly a
different Jesus a false Christ so be
praying for your Adventist friends and
family that affirm this Jesus that they
would come to know the true and living
God if you found today's video helpful
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe and ring the notification Bell
so you can be notified when content like
this is uploaded as always I'll catch
you guys around next time God bless
[Music]
thank you